It's time for Drew's News.
A Drew's News a day keeps the sads away.
And with me at the desk,
he always put some pep in my step,
it's Rossy Ross Matthews.
Yeah.
Hi everybody.
(audience cheering)
Cute.
Aren't we just the mauve twins today?
I know! And then there's mauve. (laughs)
Bea Arthur?
Yeah!
Yes! Okay.
Okay. We'll get right into it.
First up, does everyone have that friend
who loves to cozy up in bed at night
with a terrifying murder show?
Yes.
Uh-huh.
Well, a new study says that that person is probably
a lady.
A lady?
Uh-huh.
The Daily Mail reports
a survey out of Australia found that women
are way more into crime shows than men.
45% of women said it was their favorite genre
and social scientists have tons of theories on this.
Maybe it makes women feel more prepared.
For what?
Right?
Maybe it's a form of exposure therapy.
Ay-ay-ay.
Morbid.
Maybe it's just an adrenaline rush. Whoa.
You get your kicks off in a weird way.
Now murder shows are like the cilantro of TV.
It really divides people.
Ross, fan or not?
Not so much, Drew, sorry -
Because you're not a lady?
Well thank you, for noticing.
But also like, when I'm at home by myself
and I'm about to go to bed,
the last thing I want to watch is, no, thank you.
I'm turning on Golden Girls, Jem and the Holograms.
Something else.
(Drew laughs)
And I have so many girlfriends
who are obsessed with crime podcasts, crime shows,
and then they call me when they're scared.
Like, oh my gosh, I just watched this show
and I just heard a noise. Don't watch it.
(audience laughter)
All right. I would love to get another take on this.
And we have a real true crime aficionado
in our audience today, Whitney.
Whitney, where are you?
Hi!
(audience applause)
You're one of my girlfriends who calls me late at night
'cause you're scared.
Yeah.
What do you watch? What do you listen to?
Oh, all the Law and Orders,
the little doink-doink sound really gets me
I'm like, okay, it's going to happen now.
Like, so, yeah.
The doink-doink sound,
I totally know what you're talking about!
What do you like about them?
I feel like I can relate just as a human.
And so it kind of makes me feel like
God forbid I'm in that situation.
Like maybe I could talk my way out of it or something.
So that's one of the reasons I watch it.
Who likes to watch like crime and murder and all of it?
Cause you know, even People magazine always has true crime
and we get these reports,
it's so fascinating about people's watching habits
and true crime rates number one.
Wow.
We are all sick, sick, sick.
Yes! You all twisted!
(audience applause)
You know, we solve some crimes of our own around here.
It's true because I got this data, I was like, okay,
we have to do something on the show. And you know,
we're not really that show that wants to like, I mean,
I'm fascinated by the mind of a madman too, Whitney.
Like I really am, but you know, we were like,
what's our version of it?
So we have Drew Crime
and this has been a really popular fun segment for us.
We've had Deborah Norville, Keith Morrison.
Hota.
Hota Kotb.
They've all done it.
(audience applause)
So tell them about the YouTube.
Well, you can catch up with Drew Crime
on youtube.com/thedrewbarrymoreshow
You can watch the kind of fun.
Now that's some crime I can get into. Thank you very much.
Hey, speaking of particular tastes and habits,
we just learned about a real quirky way, Jessica Simpson,
she likes to eat breakfast.
We have to talk about this.
People reports she posted a pic of her
and her daughter Maxwell sharing some bacon,
which I love bacon.
And she admitted that when she eats bacon, she only eats
the tips.
Just the tip?
Just the tip, yeah.
(laughs)
Yeah, no, no.
Okay.
(audience laughter)
Don't do this to me.
I do have to say the tip is always the crispiest part,
right, of the bacon.
(audience laughter)
You know,
I have a highly addictive personality
and I don't think I can do it. I gotta go whole hog here.
Oh!
Oh! Oh! Oh!
(audience applause)
I think I officially just pulled a Ross.
I am so proud of you. You are such a ham.
(audience laughter)
Well, I'm not going to finish this
'cause I'm so much like just get some sin that way.
And I need you to learn more from her apparently. Okay.
We're going all the way to Glasgow, Scotland
for our next story.
The good news network reports one nightclub is launching
a body heat sustainable energy technology
that will use body heat from dancers
to power the venue. This is real.
I know.
I thought this was the coolest story.
They use heat pumps to capture the heat from all
the booty shakers and twerkers and turn it into electricity.
There's also a lot of this, you know,
if you've been all up in the club, you know that move,
Ross, I don't know about you, I mean this moment runs hot.
Do you think that we could power the entire studio?
I mean, listen, I love people -
(audience applause)
Listen. I do. I love people,
but normally the only time I want a stranger's body heat
is in an avalanche, but I am willing to try it
with all of you here.
(audience applause)
Will you guys try it with us?
All right guys, we're going to dim the lights,
Tony, it's all about you.
All right, let's do this everybody, stand up.
Let's stand up everybody.
Everybody up!
(dance music)
Let's power this baby.
(audience clap in rhythm)
Turn it up!
Tony got the fast beat. Yeah!
Twerk it!
Harder, harder, harder, harder!
Yes, yes, yes!
Harder, harder!
Hey, we did it!
We did it!
Yes!
(audience applause)
Bravo! Yes!
You guys,
our tushies turned on the light.
Ooh!